hello everybody my name is markiplier
this is Tyler who are you he passed he
pass we're gonna make Lego that's what
we got right here we're gonna be making
like a we each have different Lego boxes
boy we don't know what they look like
we've never seen these before you guys
can see what we're trying to make right
now cuz I'll put a graphic of it later
I'll put an insert shot of us holding up
the boxes or something like that but we
don't know what they look like all we
kind of know is that they're cars maybe
it might be something else it's up to
invention and imagination but these are
supposed to work these are the type of
Legos that actually are supposed to move
so ya won't step on the gas you call he
backs turn that [ __ ] to glass you'll
call he pass you want to smoke some
grass you call he pass by fast smoke
grass but not that I need to pass a test
he pass I was in the middle of a bit
dinner you see what I'm talking in my
bit and then you talk that's not how
that one my bit my bit and my [ __ ]
ruined it's all gone so little history
of Legos I think these are Legos are
these alekos yeah I'm getting
confirmation from the studio these are
Legos Playmobil made by Lego right want
to get a confirmation on that one we
don't know LEGO Group all right these
are Legos so a little backstory on Legos
Legos were originally made by a NASA
scientist when he was trying to make a
more portable form of brick bricks big
heavy you want small so he took
normal brick let me put it in a
microwave and just magically start
congealing into a tiny itty bitty brick
and then he gave it to his kid or
something in his kid was like wow super
fun this is great I love this dad I
finally have some reason to love you and
then the dad was all like
microwaved more bricks like I don't know
how to make my kid love me other than
this
so he started microwaving more bricks
and eventually he came up with this
Legos by the way it was a special NASA
microwave don't try microwaving bricks
at home you get microwave for brick at
home along with that metal in them they
could kids microwave bricks right now go
to your house take a hammer smash a
brick out of your house grab that brick
pop that bad boy in a microwave see what
happens I bet it won't blow up see what
happens I bet your parents will lose
their deposit if they're renting the
house yeah exactly you want to live fast
fall he passes Louise microwave a brick
don't know he's doing he lives like on
the edge yeah this is a bizarre cuz I
don't have wheels now let's start what
are you doing no explain what were you
doing I was putting your bowls in the
way you can my wheel yes I'll take it
off
alright this really funny and clever and
frankly this is why everyone loves you
but please stop it right now
wait don't you dare talk to he pass like
that you're right what are you doing no
car could you stop you would give you
these bowls for a reason
okay so I say 15 minutes is a good
amount of time to try to build a Lego
thing and whoever's closest to the
design whoever's most true to what it is
and whoever's works the best is the
winner makes sense
15 minutes put it on the clock will go
on your go so I'm starting out by
figuring out what pieces look like other
pieces because I'm assuming this has
some sort of symmetry right what do you
think yours is if you don't have wheels
wait I got wheels wait they're tiny
they're tiny listen it's not about the
size of the wheels I think yours are
really big I'm just worried that like
they got you like sweet awesome teenage
like level Legos and I got some wimpy
baby Legos I don't know your said power
level Legos I think mine's a police car
cuz it says don't talk about the pies we
can't talk about how we efficiently
stack these recordings like intelligent
you if you want to be a youtuber and
you're trying to get a lot of videos out
try to stack your recording days all in
one and then you can get a lot done in a
little bit of time and if you stack them
even if you need to wait on one video
start another video wouldn't be so bad
that's a little markiplier tip for all
you burgeoning youtubers out there tell
them the definition of burgeoning one
who virgins in the field one who likes
to burgeon themselves - I'm so glad
- virgin so glad I paid for all your
improv lessons you're welcome
how much time ago
what I've done nothing
I don't understand how there's so many
pieces was there look at time
recommendations or this thing because
holy crap okay but how much of you don't
have instructions this is so many tiny
pieces do this how would anyone build
this even if they had the instructions
oh my god it's got a gear mechanism oh
my god there are gears I'm getting
somewhere that's really a hard-ass how
am I supposed to talk to you he says
what would you prefer kindly use your
inside voice risky pass he pass your
[Laughter]
[ __ ] ten minutes left for ten minutes
we've gone why wouldn't why would you
say no
Marga bar makes Edward have we counted
up no it's almost more this is brutal
wow that's surprising I'm not gonna be
able to test mine cuz what am I gonna
put mine in the wall okay I just took
mine apart
well cube man all right everybody stop
what you're doing show your progress
your bowl there hey don't mess with my
part you put your ball in front of my
bowl yeah then it makes no difference
then when you put your boy in front of
you I didn't you didn't have to move
your ball I put it there because it was
the most out of the way they could
possibly be of all the places that I
could put here behind the bowl that was
already blocking you was the most
acclamation aplace I mean you're
logically sound but the
make it give me the definition of
acclamation bowl that's not a word
acclamation about to make [ __ ] up in
seven minutes I have managed to separate
the majority of my pieces kind of
categorize them kind of put them like
next to some things that are kind of
similar I think that if I do this I can
kind of get an idea of where I'm going
with it and then I can like you know how
Tony Stark he is like the thing in front
of his face you know he was like that is
what I'm gonna be like I decided to just
go balls deep and just start putting the
wheels and the engine and the chassis
together I have a question dived in
headfirst and went straight straight in
all the way what's an engine I don't
know yeah I was thinking about that for
you you know these actually work though
because I don't see a place to like turn
these yours wheels I know I have wheels
doesn't make it a car or your why do you
only have three wheels
there's a boat boat if three wheels what
that's true I've been around a lot of
boats boats don't have three wheels
these wheels
spongebob there are a lot of
three-wheeled boats actually true that
is fair but that's fair is fair Tyler
fair is fair damage
oh hang on with my bowl what my blip no
all right fine you know what you know
everyone's out to get me because I'm
clearly the front-runner I'm just
concerned I don't have a motor I've got
a fake motor this is not a real motor
but are these even real motors because
there's nothing there's no way to turn
it on you right now okay what this is
wheels years engine oh oh when will you
learn are you tired the boy woke me up
woke me up straight he's just walking
down the middle of the street 3:00 a.m.
glowing eyes floating a foot off the
ground look boy no boy no not my soul
not again it says snippets of facts like
if the app is free you're the thing
being sold
I woke boy hanging that way how how am I
gonna how all right you know what
everyone's out to get me because they
know I'm the front-runner so how do you
keep thinking that well what else am I
gonna think thank you thank you I
appreciate you and I appreciate your
updates
I wouldn't love that yeah whoa whoa but
I'm ahead then now it's gonna make me
have to recreate things I saw disaster
coming okay okay how much somebody
haven't told don't don't you dare
no okay no Peskin are you drain the
phone a friend
no all right that didn't help at all
why the bye oh boy oh boy oh well that's
gone uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh
oh yeah go on uh-huh I'm listening I am
listening and I'm hearing and I am just
I care about what you have to say I care
so much about what you have to say and
all of your emotions
I am very attentive all right
[Laughter]
oh wait give my side bye don't forget
about mine wait watch the action you
know kind of like a streamlined
minimalist look I think there's a lot of
detail in here that's unnecessary I felt
like I could really pare down the
formula and unlike most posts this one
can go sideways I think 9 wins for
distance mine actually self propels mine
and stops itself because do you have to
bring it backwards first yeah but I
don't have to apply forward force to
determine its distance it makes its own
have you the fancy words you fill this
up with water please oh all right
where's my water where's my Wawa hey you
go boy ok I'm gonna bring this close to
this camera so you can see the bolt
action if if this floats I win right
no sure I'm not a girl I agree to it
majority vote why are you I bet you
mindful no way no so we all make votes
no no you failed at your cars I'm sorry
I clearly went up my my car sucks so it
was car all right well I guess we need a
third party judge well
the categories authenticity to the
design function functionality
originality so really we all were all
winners
we all win well thank you he pass Thank
You Tyler thank you for joining me on
this adventure if you've got other
things that you want us to try to make
let us know down in the comments below
if you need any life advice contact he
pass 1 888 HEA PA SS 1 888 he pass call
that number ask for mr. he pass himself
any problem you have he will help you or
you can email he heaps ass gmail.com
yeah that's heaps ass not he bass thank
you he passes Thank You Tyler and as
always see it oh if you want to see more
of our guitar makes there's a link in
the description with the playlist go see
all the videos there's a ton now like
over 10 they're great they're all great
really good stuff thank you again and as
always we'll see you in the next one bye
bye